hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast single-cell analysis of
virus effect infection Zika and beyond
presented by dr. Eric Lambie we're
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab lives in
sponsored by our metrics happy metric c
bioscience technologies enable multiplex
and simultaneous analysis of biological
systems of the cell protein and gene
level facilitating the rapid translation
of benchtop research into clinical and
routine use for human health and
wellness Affymetrix part of thermo
Fisher Scientific provides leadership
and support partnering with customers in
pharmaceutical diagnostic and
biotechnology companies and leading
academic government and nonprofit
research institutes in their quest to
use biology for a better world to learn
more please visit WWE do science comm I
proceeded role of lab words and I'll be
your moderator for today's event before
we begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you will be viewing a presentation
in the slide window to large the window
just click on the screen icon located on
the lower right if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or use the Q&A button to let us know
you're having a problem this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the Save
button located in the bottom left-hand
corner of your web page involve the
process of obtaining your credits I
would now like to introduce our speaker
dr. Eric Randy dr. Eric teeth can be
received his PhD degree from Washington
University in
st. Louis he's currently an assistant
professor at the University of Colorado
School of Medicine department of
anesthesiology and program in immunology
and director of the University of
Colorado Cancer Center low cytometry
shared resource his research program
focuses on the dynamic interface between
immune system infection inflammation and
tissue repair please join me in
welcoming dr. Eric clampy I will now
turn the presentation over to him dr.
clampy uh good morning Thank You
Kristina for that introduction I'm Eric
Lambie and I'm at the University of
Colorado Anschutz medical campus and
today I'll discuss some of our ongoing
research focused on single-cell analysis
of RNA expression my lab really focuses
on the interaction between the immune
system and infectious and non-infectious
challenges and today I'll discuss some
of our ongoing work investigating viral
gene expression in the context of
diverse infections so before I get
started I have no financial conflict of
interest it is worth noting that I was a
recipient of the 2016 Affymetrix
single-cell grant and that mechanism
gave me many many of the supplies that
we used for the talk I will discuss now
so today's talk is really focused around
understanding RNA expression at the
single cell level and while conventional
assays typically to measure RNA
typically focus on using pooled material
where you're pulling tens to millions of
different cells and then subjecting them
to downstream analyses ranging from
northern blot to PCR or microarray
analysis but a fundamental challenge
with this method is that it provides an
average signal of RNA expression if you
consider
two different scenarios in which there
might be comparable levels of RNA in
that population here on the left
considering a population of cells in
which there is homogeneous expression of
your RNA of interest now note that this
he is a bulk analysis you can't
discriminate between whether there's
homogeneous expression or heterogeneous
expression indicated here and for
example in this middle path in this
middle panel where there is
heterogeneity you can see that some
events are characterized by very low
expression whereas other events are
characterized by very high expression
for example the cell here in red now
this example focuses on a single RNA but
if you start thinking about a complex
tissue where there are multiple cell
types or if you start thinking about
multiple RNAs you can quickly see that
the the complexity of RNA expression can
really be obscured by using analyses in
which you use pooled cellular material
now today we'll focus on a some of our
studies in which we've really focused on
using a single cell method flow so top
flow cytometry to analyze RNA expression
now importantly this these assays use
genes with gene specific fluorescence to
detect RNAs within intact cells
importantly by retaining the cellular
context in which RNAs are expressed this
allows you to define be able to define
Co expression relationships with other
RNAs proteins media types all at the
single cell level something which is
which is obscured by conventional pooled
analyses and so today we'll talk about
two projects in which we've made use of
this single cell methodology first we'll
talk about our studies investigating
Zika virus
in particular which is a single strand
RNA virus addressing the question how
uniform are viral RNAs at the single
cell level in the second part of the
talk will focus then on a different
class of viruses the herpes viruses to
ask the question how uniform is viral
gene expression at the single cell level
the goal in both of these studies is by
analyzing our an expression by flow
cytometry at the single cell level we
hope to gain new insights into virus and
host RNA regulation during infection so
much of today's studies will focus on
use of this RNA detection platform which
was which we obtained from a symmetric
sandy bioscience particularly the prime
flow for prime flow RNA acid so this
assay relies on branched DNA harbors a
ssin to achieve a high level of
specificity and sensitivity as an is
essentially a highly optimized
fluorescent in situ hybridization assay
to allow detection of RNAs at the single
cell level so in this assay there are
multiple steps for example with your
target RNA there are first are a series
of multiple probes spanning your target
RNA of interest and typically RNA is our
target targeted between by twenty to
forty probes that span your target RNA
of interest building on this initial
scaffold of the target RNA there is then
subsequent amplification pre-application
and amplification that allows for a
pronounced amplification of the
fluorescence signal and so estimates are
that there's approximately an 8,000
8,000 to 16,000 fold amplification of
signal detection using this format
so the prime flow RNA assay involves
multiple steps first you have first you
have sample preparation in which you can
label your label yourselves with
antibodies for example you then fix
impermeable eyes these cells in
suspension next there is gene specific
next you have gene specific fluorescence
in which you think about yourselves with
your target probes of interest and
importantly this methodology allows you
to detect up to three RNA is
simultaneously in different fluorescent
channels following this target
hybridization there is then signal
amplification followed by ultimately by
detection using conventional flow stump
flow cytometry and so if you think about
what this system is affording you this
system allows you simultaneous detection
of at least three different RNAs
detected with different fluorophores now
the assays that we've used to date have
focused on three floors alexa fluor 488
647 and 750 is worth noting that there
is now a fourth channel available which
further expands the ability to
combinatorially assess RNA expression
one really powerful thing about this is
not only does it allow you to detect
different multiple RNAs but you can also
have simultaneous expression of protein
expression at the single cell level
another really beautiful thing about
this method is it allows you to detect
endogenous RNAs without RNA purification
so in total this platform allows direct
single cell measurement of RNAs and it
really bypasses two major limitations of
conventional bulk analysis first it
bypasses the need to pool cellular
material and secondly it removes the
requirement for Standardization relative
to a housekeeping gene
so the first part of the talk I'd like
to focus on our studies on Zika virus
now undoubtedly have heard about Zika
virus there's a lot of concern in terms
of Zika virus and its impact on public
health and Zika virus is an arthropod
borne virus or Ann Arbor virus it is in
the flavivirus family and is in along
with additional viruses including dengue
West Nile and yellow fever viruses now
the Zika virus is a positive sense
single strand RNA virus and that's
really one reason why we wanted to make
use of this RNA analysis platform the
prime envelope format because we wanted
to be able to directly attacked the
viral genome directly measuring the
single strand RNA in infected cells now
zika virus is known to be transmitted by
mosquitoes but it there's also now clear
evidence of human human transmission
including a maternal the fetal
transmission sexual transmission and
blood transmission which has raised many
concerns okay
finally while Zika virus Zika virus is
associated with disease in that and that
occurs in approximately 20% of adult
patients so Zika virus induced disease
occurs when there are clinical symptoms
in an infected individual and that
occurs in approximately 20% of adult
patients the symptoms for this include
in healthy adults include fever rash
nausea myalgia and conjunctivitis and
it's worth noting that there also are
rare cases in which there are severe
complications of Zika infection in
adults including individuals who develop
beyond baray syndrome perhaps the most
notable and concerning feature of Zika
virus induced disease has been noticed
in the context of birth defects and now
there's then there's clear linkage
between Zika virus infection and
birth defects including growth
restriction intrauterine growth
restriction spontaneous abortion and
microcephaly now one thing that's worth
noting is that although Zika was
identified in late 1940s it wasn't until
the recent transmission of Zika to the
new world that it's become a center of
investigation or it's become a topic of
investigation and so while there is a
lot of information about related
flaviviruses there's none as much
information in terms of Zika virus
itself now Zika virus is a like I
mentioned it's a positive strand
positive single strand RNA genome okay
and the genome is approximately eleven
thousand nucleotides long
now Zika virus encodes a single open
rain frame which encodes as a single
poly protein which undergoes proteolytic
processing and that's indicated by these
two result from these multiple protein
products indicated on the cartoon it's
also worth noting that Zika virus has
both a v prime untranslated region as
well as a 3 prime untrained untranslated
region and these regions are highly
structured RNAs which are which promote
both virus translation and replication
and so the question for today's talk
that I'd like to share with you is how
uniform or heterogeneous are Zika virus
RNAs at the single cell level now it's
worth noting that we have focused on
detecting the positive strand of the art
of the zika RNA we are now investigating
cell used to look at the negative strand
which is involved in replication so
for this first part of the talk we focus
on on the detection of two different
portions of the Zika virus genome first
we focused first we have probes which
can detect the Zika or for open reading
frame now this is on the positive single
strand RNA genome and the Orphic spans a
sequence of two thousand two hundred six
ten thousand 216 nucleotides this Worf
encodes for the viral viral polyprotein
and it's also packaged as the virus
genome as is the entire positive single
strand RNA the or is also a template for
replication and translation so that's
the first target that we're going to
focus on today but we've also analyzed
we'll also design probes to measure the
three prime untranslated region or three
prime UTR now importantly the three
prime UTR is collinear with the ourf
meaning that they are expressed on the
exact same strand on the exact same RNA
and that's important to realize the
three prime UTR is a much shorter
sequence it's only 428 nucleotides long
but one reason that were particularly
interested interested in three prime UTR
is it as it is a highly conserved
element the three prime end of zika
virus and it has a high degree of
secondary and tertiary structure and so
we were particularly interested in
whether this highly structured 3 prime
UTR might be differentially regulated in
the context of cellular degradation of
Zika virus genomes and I'll talk about
that in a few slides
ok
so when we begin these days we first
made use of in vitro infection of vero
cells in the bureau cells are a highly
permissive cell for Zika virus
replication in vitro we chose to infect
cells using an intermediate multiplicity
of infection meaning that only part of
the part of the cells would be infected
in the culture and we did this on
purpose so that we could discriminate
between both infected and uninfected
cells in here what I'm showing you is
flow cytometry analysis using the prime
flow format and on the y-axis here we're
looking at side scatter or granny or
granularity and on the x-axis we are
looking at fluorescence for the Zika
virus open reading frame RNA detecting
with an Alexa fluor 647 conjugated
fluorophore probe and what you can see
is that in the left-hand plot these are
mock infected cells and as you would
predict there is there are no cells
which are positive for the Zika virus
open rain frame indicated by this
positive paucity of events in the right
plot now when we infected cells when we
infected cells with Zika virus on the
right hand panel we found that there was
a clear positive population of cells
which showed robust staining for the
Zika virus or if RNA probes indicated by
this red arrow there so based on this
analysis of a mixed culture of infected
and uninfected cells it's clear that
using the prime flow format we can
readily detect the single strand the
single strand positive sense RNA of Zika
virus followed in vitro infection okay
and we've also been able to obtain very
comparable results when we've analyzed
expression of the three prime UTR
in the zika virus infected
sells so that's a single parameter and
that already affords unique insights
because for example if you look at the
spread of Zika virus or RNA you can see
that there is a spread in terms of how
many of the relative intensity in or if
are na+ cells now we wanted to increase
the complexity and here what we're doing
is we're using the prime flow system to
analyze two assignments simultaneously
measure two Zika virus RNAs so on the
x-axis again we're measuring the Zika
virus or RNA and on the y-axis we're
measuring the Zika virus three prime
untranslated region as expected mock
infected samples on the left hand side
here have no positive signal for either
the Zika virus or RNA or the three prime
UTR conversely when we looked at cells
that were which were infected with Zika
virus again at this intermediate
multiplicity of infection to give both
infected and uninfected cells we found a
clear population of cells which were
robustly positive for both Zika virus or
ironing as well as for the 3-prime utr
now one of the things that was
unexpected from this analysis is we
already know that the Zika virus or and
3-prime utr
are co-linear meaning that they're on
the same positive strand of the Zika
virus genome and they're on the same
they're on the same RNA and so one would
predict that there would be a one-to-one
correlation in terms of detection of the
Zika virus or RNA and the Zika virus
three prime UTR one of the things that
really surprised us was while we
identified cells which were had high
expression of the Zika virus forth and
3-prime utr indicated in this top right
column
in the in the box highlighted in red we
also found a second population of cells
which were positive for Zika virus RNAs
and those are indicated in this blue box
and these events where Zika virus or RNA
positive but had low to undetectable
levels of the Zika virus three prime
untranslated region it's worth noting
that in these mixed cultures we also
found a clear uninfected population
which was negative for both Zika virus
RNAs and so one question that we're very
interested interested in is what is the
significance of Zika virus or RNA
positive cells with a low three prime
UTR abundance okay so one of the
beautiful things about flow cytometry is
that you can analyze your different
populations by multiple parameters so
here for example I have color-coded the
three different populations that we have
in these cultures looking at infected
cells in grey the Zika virus or RNA
through prime UTR low events in blue and
looking at the zika virus or high three
prime UTR high events in red and when we
look at those parameters and we can then
analyze them by additional additional
florescent properties if you look at the
bottom what we've done is we've done
histogram overlays comparing the forward
scatter or cell size in comparing cells
with zika virus RNA versus uninfected
and what you can see here for example is
that there's a modest increase in terms
of the cell size of cells which contain
Zika virus RNAs and that's true
regardless of the relative expression
level of the Zika virus RNAs
when we look at side scatter or
granularity we also find a modest
increase in terms of granularity of Zika
virus positive cells
now when you look at the Zika virus or
RNA and the Zika virus 3-prime utr what
you can see is but there's really a wide
range in terms of Zika virus or RNA and
3-prime utr when you compare the red and
the blue populations and so one notable
thing about this is that the blue
population which expresses the Orff but
has low untechnical 3-prime utr
it has both decreased levels of Zika
virus or RNA as well as the 3-prime utr
and then finally in this analysis we've
included hybridization for a cellular
transcript focused on actin RNA and you
can see that actin RNA expression is
equivalent across all Commission's
indicating that in Zika virus infection
has no consequence on actin RNA so one
of the things I mentioned was that Zika
virus and flaviviruses are antagonized
by certain cellular processes and it's
known that the flaviviruses have a
highly structured three prime
untranslated region now importantly
studies by multiple groups have shown
that there is a mechanism in place a
cellular mechanism in place by which a
cellular XA nucleus here referred to as
xrn one is a protein which is capable of
degrading flavivirus genomes and what
happens with when X R and one degrades
the cabarrus genomes from the 5-prime
and 3-prime end is that XR n one is
capable of degrading through most of the
flavivirus genome however importantly
when it reaches this highly structured
portion of the three prime untranslated
region this region is so structured that
X R and one has is incapable of
completely digesting this highly
structured RNA and as
the 3-prime utr of Zika virus another
flaviviruses contain xrn one resistant
elements and the reason that that's
important is that during flava virus
infection what happens is that you have
an accumulation of sub genomic fragments
of flavivirus genome which are not
degraded by xr1 and here on here you can
see the accumulation of some of these
three prime untranslated region
fragments which were is just x earned
and one degradation so with this in mind
we wanted to ask the question what is
the consequence of depleting xrn 1 on
the frequency and Meg or magnitude of
cells express the Zika virus RNAs and
we'll look at both the ourf RNA as well
as the three prime untranslated RNA and
so when we've done this we've made use
of again in vitro infection here we're
using a five for nine cells in which we
have made use of RNA interference and we
have two Commission's we have on the
left hand side we have cells which are
which were transfected with the
scrambled small interfering RNA on the
right hand side we have cells in which
we've depleted cells of XR and one using
an xrn 1si RNA in this assay we've been
we have two Commission's that we're
comparing we have we have mock infection
and we have Zika virus infection so here
for example in the second plot we're
looking at cells which have been
transacted with a scrambled si RNA and
infected with Zika virus and what you
can see is that 33.8% of cells in this
culture are positive for Zika virus or
if RNA as detected by prime flow now
it's also worth noting that there's
clearly a spread in terms of the range
of intensity for the hora RNA positive
cells with some cells being low and some
cells being high interestingly into our
surprise when we depleted cells of X R
and one using RNA interference we found
that there was only a modest change in
terms of the frequency of cells which
were Zika virus or for RNA positive
going up to 39.1%
but then look at the intensity of these
of these or for any positive events
they're really focused in terms of a low
expression of the orphe RNA and
conversely
there's essentially a dropout of cells
that were C Zika virus or RNA hi
now you can quantify that bye bye
Felicity time three and what you can see
is that there's approximately a two-fold
or 50% reduction in the mean florist
intensity of the Zika virus or RNA when
you consider cells which are Zika virus
or far na+ okay so this result was
really surprising because the the
paradigm in the field is that exon one
degrades the Zika virus genome and so if
anything we would have anticipated that
by depleting exon 1 we would have had an
increase in the amount of Zika virus
genomes at work that we could detect but
that's clearly not what we're seeing
here so two major take-home points from
this analysis one Zika virus infection
is associated with a range of
intensities for the or ferny and XR and
one depletion has a modest effect on the
frequency of infected cells but it
decreases the overall abundance of or
RNA within infected cells so we're
really interested in in these
observations and are actively pursuing
to two major questions here one why are
there varying intensities of Zika virus
or ironing in infected cells is this an
issue of kinetics or a genome and
location and what's the relationship to
the three prime untranslated region we
also really want to know what happens
when you deplete X are in one why is
there reduced genome amplification it's
worth noting too that XR and one does
regulates both cellular and viral
processes and so it's possible that the
effects that we're seeing here are
secondary due to some other perturbation
that occurs following XR and one
depletion so what I've shown you thus
far is focused on the Zika virus or RNA
so let's turn to the three prime
untranslated region so one of the things
that was very surprising with this was
here we're focused on analysis of the
Zika virus three prime untranslated
region again measuring it by the prime
flow and so on the x axis here we're
measuring the Zika virus three prime UTR
again on the left hand side we're
looking at scrambled si rn8 transfected
cells versus the right hand side in
which we're focusing on cells which are
X R and one depleted this analysis
revealed another surprise about the
interaction between Zika virus and XR n1
so if you look on the left hand side you
can see that 14.6% of cells are positive
for the Zika virus three prime UTR
following transfection of cells with the
scrambled si RNA so those are our
control cells but look at what happens
when you deplete X R in one and that's
over here on the right what you can see
is that we significantly increase the
frequency of cells which are positive
for the three prime UTR
and so we're going from 14.6%
of cells which are three prime UTR
positive in the Scramble commission two
29.3%
themselves transfected with a with XR
and one to police depleting reagents now
notably the mean fluoresce intensity is
quite comparable between these two
conditions
so based on this our conclusion is that
XR and one depletion results in an
increased frequency of cells with Zika
virus three prime UTR and this really
minimal changes in terms of the overall
abundance and so we're getting more
cells which are positive for the Zika
virus three prime UTR following XR and
one depletion so that immediately raises
multiple questions first well what we'd
like to focus on next is why is XR n one
knockdown associated with more Zika
virus three prime UTR positive cells one
possibility is that there are altered
RNA species generated during XR n one
depletion we're also very interested in
whether XR n one degrades the Zika virus
three prime UTR and some infected cells
but not in other cells okay so can a
broad strokes of what we seen in the
context of Zika virus so first we have
the observation that there appears to be
this discordance between the Zika virus
or RNA and 3-prime utr and that's
depicted here again on this flow
cytometry plot plot and in this analysis
we've identified that there are selves
with high expression of the Zika virus
or F and three prime UTR
but we've also identified a population
which is characterized by a lower
expression of the orphe RNA and lo to
negative expression of the Zika virus
three prime UTR
so how do we make sense of this
well our working model is that we think
that these different paths at these two
populations reflect different stages of
virus infection or replication so for
example in the context of these double
positive events we we suspect that there
is a molar excess of of the three prime
untranslated region relative to the Zika
virus or in contrast we think that Zika
virus or RNA positive cells which are
three prime UTR low likely have a
greatly reduced frequency
of the the 3-prime utr relative to the
or RNA and this is something that we are
actively investigating now based on this
we would posit that the double positive
events really represent cells which are
late in virus replication possibly with
large accumulation of the the three
prime UTR or the or the SF RNA whereas
the or positive three prime UTR lo
events might be either early in virus in
the virus replication cycle or
alternatively it could be that there is
three prime UTR sequestration in
replication complexes so future goals
for this include really hammering out
the kinetics of these different
populations for example is there a
stepwise progression from these low
events to these double positive events
we also are very interested in gaining
molecular insights into what RNA species
are present and that we're measuring and
ultimately we'd like to know what RNAs
are present in the single versus double
positive events so in terms of the role
of xrn one and Zika virus infection our
observation is the XR 1 depletion gives
us two unanticipated changes one it
reduces the abundance of Orff RNA within
infected cells N 2 it results in an
increased frequency of 3 prime UTR
positive cells now our working model at
a broad level is the XR n 1 modifies
Zika virus RNA is to promote Zika virus
replication so one of the things
happening here well we think that in the
context of an xrn one sufficient cell
indicated here on the left hand side
that XR n one is capable of degrading
many Zika virus genomes as well as miss
shapen ER or a regular 3 prime utrs
indicated here in blue
ultimately however there's xr1 is
incapable of degre in many of the three
prime utrs and that's why you had this
accumulation of three prime utrs
indicated here now conversely in the
context of xrn one knockdown we think
that there is likely altered processing
of the zika virus genome and whether
that results in a reduced genome
amplification or virus replication we
also suspect there there might be
aberrant RNA species that are generated
following xrn one depletion and whether
that's a direct consequence of xrn one
depletion or a secondary consequence
that extra and one depletion remains to
be determined
so that's far I focus on our analysis of
Zika virus which is a which is a plus
strand single-stranded RNA virus so next
I'd like to focus on a short analysis of
herpes virus infection and this is a
very different type of infection but I
think our studies illustrate some of the
power of looking at RNA analysis at the
single cell level so herpes viruses are
completely different from Zika virus
there are large double strand DNA
viruses that can result in multiple
outcomes and so herpes virus infection
can result in two widely divergent
outcomes one it can result in something
called lytic infection and during lytic
infection there is abundant viral gene
expression there is new virus produced
but today I'd like to emphasize and show
you some data on is a process referred
to as virus induced host mRNA
degradation or host shut off depart
these viruses are also capable of
establishing something referred to as a
latent infection and that's indicated
here on the right hand side and latent
infection is characterized by really
limited RNA expression and so
with these divergent outcomes we're
really interested in how RNA regulate
RNA is being regulated at the single
cell level now let's talk about this
virus induced host shut off so what is
it well during lytic replication by many
herpes viruses there is degradation of
both viral and cellular mRNAs and
importantly this virus induced hosh off
involves both viral and host nucleases
and so if you look here the first step
in this degradation process occurs
through a viral into nucleus but
importantly following initial cleavage
by viral and in nucleuses cellular x and
nucleus has come in and participate in
aggradation of these target rnas and
you'll note the XR and one is one of
these X the nucleus is involved in
degradation of these RNAs following
lytic ordering in lytic replication okay
so we wanted to study this process of
host shut off using a mirroring gamma
peas for r68 and this is a mouse animal
model for the human camera Brie's
viruses including epstein-barr virus and
Kaposi sarcoma associated her associated
herpes virus when strengths of the game
each e68 system for the purpose of this
talk is that this virus is capable of
inducing establishing a very robust
lytic replication system in vitro which
is characterized by this virus induced
host shut off and below is just a
schematic of the genomic complexity of
MHC 68 the virus that we're studying so
like I mentioned herpes virus infection
is characterized by divergent outcomes
whether oolitic infection or a latent
infection and importantly latent
infection while it's transcriptionally
client is capable it was capable of
being induced to induce reactivation and
to generate new virus progeny so we
wanted to make use of the prime float
platform to analyze these processes and
so what I'll show you now is some of our
analysis in which we focus on three
targets so first we have looked at a
partner first we've looked at rnase
focus on viral short non-coding RNAs and
these RNAs are required for optimal
gamma 268 pathogenesis in vivo and
importantly they're abundantly expressed
during virus replication
we've also analyzed beta-actin as a both
as a seller messenger RNA but also it is
known to be a target of the viral end in
nucleus and so it is known to be
degraded during virus infection so the
top two targets are RNAs we've also
focused analysis on a viral protein
which is a regulator of complement
activation and we're using that as a as
another marker of the progression of
virus replication so here what we're
gonna make use of is in vitro infection
systems to say the dynamics of RNA and
protein during herpes virus infection
and so the first thing I'd like to show
you is where we have performed de novo
infection of of marine fire blasts with
gamma C 60 and this is a process that
results in lytic replication now we've
done this an analyzed actin expression
through multiple parameters in the left
hand are in panel a here we're looking
at relative expression of actin by a
conventional asset you were using
quantitative real-time PCR what we're
comparing our cells which are mock
infected which should have normal levels
pardon me of acton versus cells which
are infected with wild type virus or
cells infected with a virus which is
deficient in the viral non-coding RNAs
and this is the rightmost is simply a
control virus for these studies so this
is conventional analysis and what you'll
what you'll notice is you see
approximately a 50% reduction in the
amount of actin standardized relative to
18s which is an RNA which is impervious
to hosts shut off so that's a
conventional assay but now let's look at
another way of another type of analysis
which is this prime flow format and this
is a panel beam and so here what we're
doing is we're using probes to recognize
the actin our mRNA the cellular act in
RNA and what we've analyzed it what
we've compared here is cells in which
there's no probe that's the top versus
mock infected which is the second line
versus wild-type
gamma 68 infection or this viral
non-coding RNA mutant the team RTK on
the bottom and what I'd like you to
notice here is that whereas mock
infection gives you a uniform positive
peak for actin when you look at cells
which are virally infected not only is
there this high population of actin but
there is a second population which is
characterized which is actin low and so
the beautiful thing about this is that
rather than is securing this variation
in terms of actin expression by pooling
cells which are both infected and
uninfected analysis of actin at the
single cell level using prime flow
really allows us to to discern that
there's a bimodal distribution of actin
and that's illustrated in panel B so
that's a single parameter so let's
ratchet the complexity up a little bit
more here and if you look in panel C
this was looking at a two dimensional
analysis in which we've focused on actin
expression on the y axis
versus you've these viral small
non-coding RNAs and the x-axis and what
you can see here is that many of the
cells present in these cultures are
characterized by by high levels of actin
expression these cells are also low for
the viral small none known non-coding
RNAs now conversely if you look at cells
which are have expressed high levels of
the viral small small non-coding RNAs
these events also are characterized by
very low expression of the actin RNA and
there's a third population here which is
characterized by intermediate expression
of the viral small non-coding RNAs but
also has normal levels of the actin RNA
and so just by looking at two parameters
the expression of two RNAs and their
relative expression to one another it's
able to reveal there are multiple
populations of cells which you would
have never been able to identify using
conventional analysis and so this is an
example where measurement of actin mRNA
levels can reveal this virus induced
host shut off and importantly this
process occurs only a subset of virally
infected cells and that these are the
cells which are characterized by high
expression of the viral SMAW small
non-coding rnas we've also made use of
detecting these viral smut small
non-coding rnas to identify rare
populations of cells so here we've made
use of is a cell line in which there is
uniform expression that the prediction
is that there will be uniform gene
expression and well I'd like to focus
your attention on this is a B cell line
which contains gamma XI 68 this virus
what we've done here is we've used prime
flow to measure the viral of small
non-coding RNAs and in the onion do
state this cell line expresses
has about 20% of the cells which express
the viral small non-coding RNAs now when
you stimulate these cells with chemical
stimulus this chemical stimulus induces
reactivation and here what we're focused
on is these cells treated with TPA which
is a pharmacologic inducer of
reactivation and when you do that you'll
notice a couple things first the overall
frequency of cells which express this
intermediate level of the viral small
non-coding rnas is fairly similar
between the tree untreated and treated
cells the thing that really pops up as a
difference however is that there's a new
population of cells that are
characterized by high expression of the
viral non-coding RNA and so by using
this technique we're really able to
focus on a rare population of cells
which are characterized by a unique
expression signature of high viral
non-coding RNAs what's really cool about
this is and exciting when you compare
the properties of these cells based on
differential expression of the viral
small non-coding RNAs
if we compare cells which are either
virus non-coding RNA mid or bright what
you can see is that cells that are that
express high levels of the viral
non-coding RNAs which is in this open
black line are characterized by by a
prominent population of cells with low
levels of actin okay and so by using
this single cell analysis we're able to
focus on a population in which 1% of the
cells have a phenotype and then we can
say what is the actin profile in the
rare population of cells and so using
this method we're able to show that
viral the cells Express high levels of
these viral non-coding RNAs have
multiple characteristics of lytic
replication they have decreased actin
RNA they have increased viral protein
expression
so from our studies on the herpes
viruses we've been able to show that
virus induced host shut off can be
measured at the single cell level and it
occurs in only a fraction of virus RNA
positive cells and so we're actively
investigating why there is kind of a
spectrum of our necks of viral RNAs and
with only a subset of cells experiencing
this act and low thia type we also have
made use of this system to investigate
an inefficient process that being
reactivation from latency if you think
about what we've shown here you
basically have really focused on a rare
population of cells in by comparing the
unenthused versus the induced condition
we've been able to identify this lone
event here which is characterized by a
really unique cluster of phenotypes so
if you think about the big picture of
what I've talked about today we really
focus on single-cell analysis of viral
and host rnase by flow cytometry we've
been making use of this methodology to
study both Zika virus which is an RNA
virus and for those studies we've been
able to directly measure the Zika virus
genome in infected cells and we've also
been able to begin to reveal unexpected
complexities in terms of the regulation
of these RNAs particularly in regard to
how they're potentially degraded by
hosts exonucleases we've also made use
of this method to interrogate rare
populations of cells for example in the
context of looking at reactivation from
latency in which there's only a rare
frequency of cells which have a
phenotype of interest but by and this
study really wouldn't have been possible
by conventional analysis using pooled
cells it would have really obscured any
changes that we'd seen by analyzing
three parameters of three different RNAs
as well as cell size granularity in a
single protein
we've also been able in the herpes of
our system to identify a whole series of
different phenotypes in which cells are
characterized by a spectrum of RNA
expression and so the real take-home
from this is that single-cell analysis
of virus and host rnase really affords
the new opportunities to understand
biology we we think that this
methodology us to understand variability
in response to therapies and to
potentially identify rare subpopulations
of cells that might be either uniquely
susceptible or uniquely resistant to
treatments of interest and ultimately
our goal in this is to understand the
extent and the and the factors which
drive variability in are an expression
of the single cell level ultimately to
be able to intervene and identify unique
therapeutics to target both rare virally
infected cells but also you can easily
imagine turning this to other types of
analysis including a study of cancer for
example so finally I'd like to
acknowledge people who facilitated this
study including Andrew Bessler in my lab
importantly this project was these
projects are really a close
collaboration with two labs David
Beckham who's an investigator who
studied Zika virus and he's a he's a
practicing infectious disease doctor and
so all of the states with Zika have been
an intimate collaboration with the
Beckham lab without one whom we couldn't
have done these studies for the herpes
of our studies that's been in close
collaboration with dr. Linda Van Dyke
and Loren OCO in her lab who have
greatly facilitated the studies and I
should say that Aaron Massey in the
Beckham lab has been critical in
allowing the prime flow analysis of zika
virus infection we have funding from the
American Heart Association NAAG and the
department of anesthesiology and that
ultimately finally I'd like to thank
people at the metrics and a bioscience
who have been great in terms of giving
new insights in terms of way
which we can really optimally use the
prime floor format to get new biologic
insights thank you very much it's time
for Q&A
so if you have any questions you would
like to ask dr. clam B please do so now
just click on the green Q&A button the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button we will answer
as many of your questions that we have
time for okay let's get started
dr. kramm be our first question is what
types of targets are detectable by crime
flow are there any limitations on what
can be detected sure so the question is
what types of targets can be detected by
prime flow and are there kind of special
considerations or things which might not
be readily detectable so we've made use
of prime flow to detect a variety of
targets and it's worth noting that this
platform really allows you to not only
look at mRNAs but also non-coding RNAs
so thus far we've been able to detect
multiple cellular mRNAs of varying
lengths and the smallest mRNA that we've
detected has been probably about
probably about 500 base pairs long when
we've analyzed non-coding RNAs we've
been able to the Zika virus 3 prime UTR
is 428 nucleotides long and the viral
small non-coding RNAs there are multiple
of these RNAs and so we're detecting a
cocktail using the cocktail of probes
let's worth noting that each new viral
non-coding RNAs is just about 100 base
pair nucleotides long and so
the longer the short of it is that this
system is very capable of detecting
shorter RNAs we have not tried detecting
micro RNAs there is a public published
reference to this from Piraeus at all
published in Nature communications 2016
also the new my understanding is the new
formulation of the prime flow from that
will be released soon has also been
optimized to potentially facilitate
detection of micro RNAs
it's one thing I would like to point out
is that the RNA is that we're detecting
our rarely abundant especially the small
ones and so that might be one
consideration for some of the studies if
you have a very scarce or a little
detected RNA that that might be pushing
the limits of detection
that means said practice at all again
have shown that this system is capable
of detecting down to ten copies of RNA
per cell in terms of structures of RNAs
the processing of the material is fairly
stringent and so at least many cellular
secondary structures are going to be are
going to be degraded or melted by these
carburization conditions one question we
do have that we're investigating now is
whether a highly structured viral RNA
such as the three prime UTR
might have some regions of
inaccessibility and we're doing that
using kind of not different probe sets
to interrogate binding capability of
different probes
maybe can you combine the prime flow
analysis with downstream analysis such
as cell sorting yes thank you thanks for
the question we're very interested in in
integrating the prime flow platform with
downstream analyses we have not yet done
that but you think about essentially the
material that you're left with at the
end of this you can run it through a
conventional flow cytometry and readily
detect those events and so for example
the ability to sort cells based on
differential RNA expression certainly I
can't think of any reason why that would
not be technically possible and that's
something that we're actively developing
one thing to note is that you won't be
able to purify a viable cells and so if
for example you wanted to sort viable
cells based on differential RNA
expression currently the prime flow
platform does not allow that nonetheless
I think that there could be a lot of
informed informative studies in which
you could sort different populations of
cells based on differential RNA
expression and then for example subject
them to quantitative PCR or to Western
blot or to RNA seek and we've been
actively discussing this with alpha
metrics and we're now investigating the
possibility of treating primed flow
treated material essentially like
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded samples
in which with the appropriate conditions
you can actually extract iearning and so
kind of the next wave of studies that
we're doing will be analyzing the
ability to sort cells and then to purify
RNA using kits which are optimized to
recover from very stringent preparation
conditions such as formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded samples but I think it
certainly should be doable and Dan
Kaufman's group just published an
analysis in which they sorted selves and
they quantified HIV
kro viral DNA following prime flow so I
think it certainly is something that
will come online and really allows even
more exciting opportunities Thank You
dr. kramm B we have so many great
questions coming in but we are almost
out of time this will have to be our
last question
Patrick Lambie what is the impact of
secondary tertiary RNA structure on
probe hybridization thank you for the
question
yes so certainly one thing to know about
the prime flow system is that optimal
it's really designed to achieve high
target specificity and sensitivity by
using a series of probes that span your
RNA of interest the reason that I
mentioned that is if you think about an
RNA that where part or portions of that
RNA might be highly structured you can
imagine that at least some of the probes
with would efficiently hybridize to
unstructured elements in those RNAs now
in terms of structured RNAs such as the
Zika virus three point three prime UTR
clearly while that is known to be a
highly structured RNA element clearly
our probes and there are only five
probes the target the Zika virus three
prime UTR and our probe set clearly they
are able to detect two sufficiently
hybridize and detect the Zika virus
through prime UTR now one thing that we
are actively investigating is whether in
the context of X R and one depletion
where we see an increase in the
frequency of cells which are seek of
iris three prime UTR positive one
possibility is that perhaps some of the
increase in frequency that we're seeing
are due to
kind of misfolded three prime utrs so
one way that we're hoping to address
that is basically by combining some of
the cell sorting approaches that I
discussed earlier and then to clone
those RNAs or sequence those RNAs to
identify whether there might be point
mutations in the three prime UTR
but the bottom line is that while
structure in extreme circumstances might
antagonize probe hydration to some
degree clearly it is not a major issue
given our robust ibly detect both the
Zika virus three prime UTR i would also
like to point out that the virus small
non-coding RNAs that we've detected in
the context of herpes viruses those RNAs
are also highly structured and they
include a hybrid between a tRNA like
molecule and like RNA stem loops and so
especially in the context of small
non-coding RNAs I think that the system
is really has been very robust for us to
be allowing us to gain new insights that
would have been very difficult to do by
conventional bulk analyses thank you for
the question I appreciate it I would
like to once again thank dr. Eric lamby
for his presentation have any final
comments for our audience yeah
at first I just like to say thank you
for your attention I really appreciate
it
we've had great success with this
analysis platform and I think I'd like
to just emphasize that some of the
insights that we're gaining really
wouldn't be possible without by
conventional assays and so certainly
while this approach doesn't answer every
every every question I think it's really
a unique tool in in a toolbox in the
scientist toolbox that can really
provide new insights that you wouldn't
be able to obtain by other methods so
I'm happy to take additional questions
and in the future and again thanks
thanks so much for your attention
thank you once again dr. Eric Lambie and
thank you to our sponsor when their
tricks for making today's broadcast
possible before we go and what I let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through Maine 10 2017 you will receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast is available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's dive event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon bye